[Musique]
voilà parfait 100 fois mieux la rue pour
moi tout seul comme si on avait besoin
d'aller s'éclater en soirée parce qu'on
est le 31 décembre le magazine lui et 0
taxi
je manque sans fromage il met
l'information et sans fromage
merci quatre cartons cooper je sèche pas
peut-être pas manichéen et compagnie
mais enfin les mecs qui s'éclate avec
moi lui bien ouais question c'est
parce que je chassais tout parce qu'ils
[Musique]
vous voyez pas ce qu'ils ont dû être
certains qu'ils
comment ça qu'est ce qu'on essaye de
dire qu'il ferait semblant de jouir les
mecs ses costumes portés mais je vais
tout vous semble en attendant toi oui
bah pas avec moi mais qu'est ce qu'on
sait c'est fou ça je le sais point
j'oubliais c'est vrai tu es une femme
est rien on va zy juste que toutes les
femmes tant semaine on gêne avec moi
évidemment je fais tous les autres
semblant de temps en temps donc c'est
rigolo quand tu crois je m'en rendrai
pas de compte
franchement non n'importe quoi
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
ça va ça va aller de travers
non tu veux boire un verre d'eau laisse
tomber
[Musique]
puis à leur personnel pourquoi ah ben
non je sais je sais mais la ville est
d'embrasser personnes aminé je suis
enseignant mais je t'embrasse
non non non non non je vais juste merci
les amis
[Musique]
mais les baies du
m
ouais
[Musique]
tu as tu des saints
vd henry
tu blagues réfléchis tu sais il se
trouve que je t'aime quoi je t'aime
et qu'est ce que je suis censé répondre
à ça pourquoi pas moi aussi et pourquoi
pas je me casse tu t'en foutrais subi
les coups de feu c'est le jour de l'an
passé quand sentir seul mais là tu
débarques comme ça tu me dis que tu
m'aimes et ça y est c'est c'est réglé je
suis désolé mais ça marche pas comme ça
mais ça marche comment je ne sais pas
mais pas comme ça et pourquoi pas comme
ça j'adore quand tu enlèves le propagent
de tout et sandwichs parce que
soi-disant allergique au lactose alors
que pas du tout j'adore que tu piques ma
crème hydratante tous les matins je
crois que l'on n'aperçoit pas c'est pas
moi jacques dehors quand à lèvres elle
tremble val tétreau hing j'adore quand
tu joues frais le mytho serge j'adore
que tu sois la dernière personne à qui
j'ai envie de parler avant de me mettre
au lit et c'est pas parce que on est
trente et un et c'est pas parce que je
me sens seul ou je sais pas quoi
c'est juste parce que quand tu te rends
compte que tu veux passer le reste de ta
vie avec quelqu'un battu vous que le
reste de ta vie démarre le plus vite
possible
c'est tout toi seul tu débarques qui me
dit un truc comme ça et maintenant c'est
impossible pour moi te détester alors je
te déteste flou je te déteste
[Musique]
juste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vt
je te fais de l'effet urgente les
talibans
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à